welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Indiana
Jones and the dial of Destiny I have
been analyzing the past Indiana Jones
films over on the Deep dive Channel and
how important these films have been to
me throughout my life as a film nerd and
there were so many fun details and Winks
in the dial of destiny that I'm gonna
break down for you new rockstars is
actually now three channels this main
channel for Easter egg breakdowns the
Deep dive and the break room which is
the new home of our panel shows and our
instant reactions subscribe to all three
and support us with an indie I love you
shirt at nerdriot.shop because we love
Indy so much okay the film opens with
the sound of ticking over the opening
credits Archimedes dial plucked in
through the notes of history but really
just the sound of Indy's apartment clock
in 1969 unlike the past four Indiana
Jones movies we do not cross dissolve
from the Paramount mountain peak logo to
some in context Peak but we do cross
dissolve from The lucasfilm Limited logo
onto the perfectly matching shape of a
latch on the back of a truck where the
Nazis have captured Indiana Jones it's
1944 after the Allies have made progress
pushing the Nazis back in Europe and he
later says Hitler has gone into hiding
but Hitler did not Retreat into his
bunker until January of 1945 but you
know hey this is a fictional timeline
here and maybe that one interesting man
who had Hitler autographed his diary in
Berlin in 1938 made him afraid of his
shadow and spooked him into a bunker
early in the opening text uses the same
exact font as the opening titles text
that we saw back in Raiders of the Lost
Ark Indie and basil Shaw are after The
Blitz of longinus the spear that a Roman
soldier used to stab Jesus Christ in the
side in the Gospel of John this article
fact came from early drafts of Lawrence
kastin's Raiders of the Lost Stark
script when this holy Lance would have
been able to decide the fate of anyone
who possessed it and this was turned
into a 1995 Dark Horse comic storyline
Indiana Jones and the Spear of Destiny
now the D aging on Harrison Ford in this
movie is truly some of the best we have
ever seen it helps that ilm had access
to hours and hours of archive reference
footage of Ford from the Last Crusade
era and Star Wars apparently they used a
new software to scrub through all this
footage and find the best shots and so
when you watch this opening sequence
some of Harrison Ford's Expressions came
from indiegler Arena Nazis in the Last
Crusade but also Han Solo's Theory and
that some Stormtroopers and Darth Vader
they mapped this digitally constructed
young Harrison Ford base over current
age Harrison Ford delivering the lines
in close-up and for the wide shots and
the stunts they use stand-in stunt
actors Mike Massa and Anthony and Gruber
Masa was forward stunt double in the
show 1923 and increment cameos later in
this movie as the Dutch bitter in
Tangiers I love how there is a perfectly
placed Bullet Hole on Indy's chest on
that Nazi uniform he's not exactly
hiding the fact that he pulled this off
a Dead Nazi but this spot on his chest
is almost exactly where he will get shot
in the chest beside Archimedes tomb
while somehow hanging in there for at
least a few hours after that remember he
has been shot nine times maybe the
bullet was stopped by another bullet
that was lodged in there mads Mickelson
plays Jurgen voller a German scientist
based on Werner Von Braun who immigrated
to the US like Von Braun did under
Operation Paperclip and helped design
the rockets that the United States used
to win the Space Race but historically
we can't forget these same guys did
build rockets that were fired at you
know London fun fact Toby Jones plays
basil in this movie and in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe he plays Arnhem Zola
who also benefited from Operation
Paperclip we learned that valer's less
interested in the lands of longinus
because it's a fake and really just
wants the Antica therea AKA Archimedes
dial so in real world history the
intakethera is a real thing it's a
mysterious mechanism discovered off the
Greek island of anticothera In 1902 a
dial filled with gears designed to
follow the planetary bodies believed to
be the oldest known example of an analog
computer due to its proximity to Corinth
into Syracuse in 2008 one project argued
that it came from the school of
Archimedes as with all Indiana Jones
movies they start with a real world
artifact and its historical Origins and
then tangents often to speculative
fiction as a film about time travel
Indiana Jones of the dial of Destiny
falls into the category I have defined
as Type 4 this always happened time
travel in which history was set on the
course it's been on by future time
traveling characters destined to loop
back in time and set it that way so the
reason Archimedes had this dial to begin
with is in the Helena of Valor and the
rest going back to 213 BC where he was
able to see this completed dial
proclaimed Eureka got a wrist watch and
gained the confidence and insight to
complete his own dial a closed loop this
movie was directed by James mangles and
this is the same type of time travel
that he used for his Hugh Jackman big
Ryan rom-com Kate and Leopold which also
uses a temporarily forming fissure in
time naturally occurring Rift in a
specific geographic location in which
characters are destined to have gone
back in time and have always been there
on this train Indy's iconic hat and his
whip are pulled out of his bag along
with a photo of Marion Ravenwood meaning
even before Crystal Skull he was still
thinking about her she is the love of
his life and I love how when Indy boards
the trade he pulls a Nazi off releasing
a classic well on scream and he uses his
whip to lasso the gun out of the Nazi's
hand and he freaking catches a bullet
that shot accidentally Fires at him like
I know the Holy Grail water didn't
actually make him Immortal but I mean
between this and the nuke in the fridge
what can't this guy do baller tries to
take the dial but he gets his face taken
out by a passing beam you would think 25
years later he'd bear some scarring but
hey let's do this we can crazily
extrapolate the timeline logic and
assume someone will use the Archimedes
dial in the future to rewind back to
that night on 1944 and stop following
from getting injured that badly so we
jump ahead to 1969 and we see Indy's
Manhattan flat on his shelves there's a
photo of Shia LaBeouf's mutt from
Crystal Skull beside a folded American
flag meaning he was killed in action
beside that photo is Sean Connery's
Henry Jones senior with his bucket hat
from the Last Crusade also Henry Jones
painting of the crucifixion from the
Last Crusade that was in his home with
Joseph vermathea riding that lion with
the Holy Grail catching Jesus's blood
and leaning against that another photo
of Marion and as Andy sleeps in the
chair in his living room his father's
other Grail art from the Last Crusade is
visible the Knight reaching for the
Grail walking across the invisible
Bridge hanging over the mantle here here
another photo of Marion is on the fridge
presumably a lead line fridge just in
case and it needs to escape another
atomic bomb we see some legal paperwork
pronouncing a separation between Marion
and indy Crystal Skull ended with him
getting married we learned later they
separated out of grief following mutt's
death in Vietnam so Andy just out of his
grief puts a magnet over Marion's face
and he grouchly tells his neighbors to
Turn Down The Beatles Magical Mystery
Tour perhaps foreshadowing the Magical
Mystery Tour that Indy will go on back
to the siege of Syracuse into 13 BC in
his classroom and he lectures about that
very battle and Archimedes role in it
and how the integathera was the one
piece of historical evidence that we
have of it all to a class who unlike his
smitten co-eds back in 1936 now couldn't
care less in an age of space exploration
at Indy's retirement party his
colleagues give him a clock which he
hands off to a hobo later not wanting to
be reminded of time and his mortality
Helena Shaw Basil's daughter AKA wombat
played by Phoebe Waller Bridge who got
on lucasfilm's radar while voicing Han
Solo's Droid l337 and solo and she is so
good in this movie meanwhile talks to a
black Hotel worker who served in World
War II and father tells him that he
didn't win the war Hitler lost it but
this hints at valer's criticism of
Hitler's failures as a wartime leader
rather than him worshiping at the altar
of Hitler Butler's group includes kleber
Boyd Holbrook and Ascension Hawk and
pontomas they're overseen by CIA agent
Mason Who actor Shawnette Renee Wilson
said was part of an initiative by the
CIA and FBI in the late 60s to recruit
black agents to infiltrate the Black
Panther Party and he retrieves his half
of the dial from his archives and
Cleaver shoots and his work colleagues
leading to a Chase through the parade
there really was an Apollo 11 ticker Day
Parade in New York City on August 13
1969 with Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin
and Michael Collins it seemed like they
move Indiana Jones to New York City just
for a classic horse Chase through a
ticker tape parade past tape
boulderesque Moon float and you know
what I'm okay with it Andy reunites with
Salah Jonathan Rhys Davies we learn and
he helped salah's family move from Egypt
to the United States during the war and
after having so many kids in Raiders 33
years later this old man still has kids
who look to be like 10 11 years old who
knows maybe singing so much Gilbert and
Sullivan just boost your libido Indian
Helena both fly Pan Am two Tangiers no
map Montage here which is just so
frustrating but we do get matching shots
of both of them looking out their
Windows to younger versions of
themselves looking out a plane window
into the past something they're gonna do
later but in this flashback with basil
we get yet another DH Terror support but
this one sometime between 1944 and
Crystal Skull in 1957. so before dhindi
was you know more pepper than Salt this
is more salt and pepper Indy tells basil
that the dial belongs to the museum yeah
nice and that's a plane lands and he
arrives at the auction at the hotel
where he meets Helena's sidekick
aspiring pilot Teddy we later learned
that she met Teddy after he tried to
pickpocket her which is exactly how
Indie met Short Round it's like poetry
it Rhymes everything's a circle I love
it and everyone crashes this auction
including baller just when it all goes
to hell and he raises his whip just to
realize everyone else is packing heat
the tables have now turned from the
classic swordsman moment in Raiders and
I love it this leads to a huge Chase
throughout town years Ballers got the
dial Helena and Teddy are on one Tuk Tuk
and he's on another Tuk Tuk and they're
all chased by Helena's Fern X little
Raheem I'm just always amazed at Indiana
Jones ability to jump from one moving
thing to another in this case his
Workshop is headed for an incoming truck
and at the last second he jumps onto
Helena's Rickshaw to avoid getting wiped
out so cool Helena and Andy speculate
about the graphic hosts that's a tablet
that will point to the location of the
second half of the dial and whether it
will be coded in Linear B or polybius
Square so Linear B is a syllabic script
used for writing in Mycenaean Greek
predating the Greek alphabet by several
centuries Olivia square is a
checkerboard that is used in
cryptography from this era as well so
they head to grease and we finally get a
map Montage it does not disappoint they
meet up with Indie scuba diver buddy
Ronaldo Antonio Banderas Helena deduces
that the Shipwreck where the first half
of the dial was discovered in 1902 since
it had 100 Roman centurions on board
must have been on a greater mission that
not just the first half of the dial was
there that they also must have had the
graphicos and were looking for the other
half and it's interesting to note that 4
intervene to sink the ship just as it
does for baller and Claver to crash
their plane at the end of this movie
while on the boat Indy says I don't
believe in magic but a few times in my
life I've seen things things I can't
explain and I've come to believe it's
not so much what you believe it's how
hard you believe I don't believe in
magic same thing he said in Raiders to
Marcus Brody I don't believe in magic a
lot of superstitious Hocus Pocus and
indy has seen a lot of things the
phenomena includes the wrath of God from
the Ark of the Covenant the blood of
Kali Voodoo mulram heart pulling Shiva
causing the stones to burn in his pouch
the Holy Grail sucking the life out of
Donovan an old freaking Knight in that
cave and Interventional aliens and
Crystal Skull so by how hard you believe
it and he's really saying that there is
divine power to all of this stuff across
belief systems and the only thing that
matters is how much you believe in it
and Indie emotionally confesses that if
he could turn back time he would tell
his son not to enlist in the Vietnam War
so that he would never die and that he
and Marion would still be together God
so sad so dive into the wreckage to get
the graphic ghosts and it is filled with
eels too similar to snakes for Indie
Ballers crew again catches up with him
they kill Ronaldo and Helena translates
the graphic ghost saying my machine lies
with me in the city I left where wolves
teach men to walk under nine I lie I
love how she puts on a show of using the
Socratic method to get everyone to join
in with it but really it's just an
excuse to hint to Indy by saying I
thought you were a bright spark as in
I'm gonna ignite that Dynamite we found
earlier but Helena puts it together
saying it's in the school of mathematics
and the nine refer to the nine Muses of
Greek mythology whom she names in
reverse order Calliope urania polyhimna
erato melee what's his name referring to
melpomani then she says that other one
referring to terpsichori which is the
most complex name everyone forgets it
then Thalia you to pray but the first is
Cleo the Muse of history and time so she
sends Baller in the direction of
Alexandria but boom goes to Dynamite and
indy realizes beneath the wax of this
graphicos is a golden a disc with the
actual resting place in Syracuse so in
this town There's a marionette puppet
show showing the Romans facing a dragon
for shadowing the history that they will
all soon alter with the planes they
travel into the ear of Dionysus which is
the Limestone cave they can actually
visit in Syracuse Indian Helena climb up
to a hidden tomb entrance in an indie
crumbly tells Helena how he once had to
drink the blood of Kali and got tortured
with Voodoo but of course referring to
the events of Temple of Doom but like a
temple of doom they now have to cross a
rickety rope bridge and they pass
through a tunnel of bugs centipedes
gross then they enter a methane field
chamber with a statue of Athena and they
can only Escape through water
displacement because Archimedes is known
for the Archimedes principle of water
displacement which is how you can
measure the volume of an irregular
shaped object and they finally reached
Archimedes tomb where Helena observes
Phoenix carvings on the side of the Tomb
but this Phoenix has propellers like
that of a plane you know the kind of
planes that chop up Nazis
Archimedes is holding the other half of
the dial but he also is wearing a
wristwatch we laid to learn baller's
watch baller arrives and he connects
both halves he calls this History's
Greatest moment its end and he gets shot
and they take him on the plane Indy
assumes they're going back in time to
kill Winston Churchill or maybe Dwight
Eisenhower but no baller's plan is to
kill Hitler in August 1939 so that a
different Nazi leader would step up and
not make the same mistakes he's
basically saying that Hitler's greatest
strength was everything leading up to
the war whereas a fascist leader he was
able to whip up Nazi Germany into a
crazy frenzy of militarization and
annexation but and he realizes that
these coordinates that they plugged in
have not taken into consideration
continental drift continental drift is a
hypothesis that due to plate tectonics
Earth's continents have gradually moved
over geologic time relative to each
other it was first introduced in 1596 by
Abraham ortelius and further developed
by Alfred Wegener in 1912. Archimedes
would know nothing about it and so
instead of Sicily in 1939 they go to I
was whispering please be dinosaurs
please be dinosaurs but no of course the
siege of Syracuse in 213 BC that Indy
lectured about we get to see all of
Archimedes War Weaponry in action the
mirrors to focus sunlight to burn the
enemy sails the mechanical Contraptions
the lasso and grab the Invaders we even
get to see the Roman leader the credits
call him Maximus this is Marcus Valerius
Maximus who led that beach Invasion all
these ancient soldiers are looking up
they're assuming the planes are dragons
we even meet Archimedes himself who
comes up upon the crash plane of older
and Claver and finds the completed dial
exclaiming yurika a nod to the
historical Legend in which Archimedes
was tasked with figuring out the density
of gold and when he did he ran make it
through the streets shouting Eureka I
found it could just be a story though
Indian Helena meet this Archimedes an
Archimedes seems to understand that they
are from the future and that it was
their Destiny to show him this completed
mechanism and he wants to stay but nah
Helen is like that you're gonna destroy
the time stream and she knocks him out
now where did Archimedes Go From Here
The Story Goes that Archimedes died when
Syracuse was eventually captured by the
Romans and he refused to meet with the
Roman leader because he was finishing a
math problem and a soldier who was
escorting him killed him out of anger
and some attributed Archimedes final
words to be do not disturb my circles
basically like don't mess with my math
please but this movie implies that those
circles were the gears and the dials of
the dial of Destiny Andy wakes up back
in his apartment and we see that he has
the dial and up into the spear that
scared the plane so finally as evidence
beyond the Antica therea that this
actually happened Helena is there and
Teddy returns with Marion Ravenwood
Karen Allen coming back Salah arrives
too and he takes someone out for ice
cream swinging some more Gilbert and
Sullivan in the hallways as he always
does Indy slightly slides the magnet off
of her fridge photo and it's so sweet
they reenact there where doesn't it hurt
kiss game from Raiders of the Lost Ark
as we hear John Williams Marion theme in
the final shot Andy's hat hanging on
that fire escape get snatched back in
through the window like Andy's always
grabbing that hat through a doorway as
we saw in Devil of Doom and this man is
not gonna bang without that hat on
please watch my breakdowns of the
Indiana Jones films on the Deep dive
you're gonna love those videos and grab
this Indie I love you shirt at nerd
riot.shop subscribe to all three
channels of our Network follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
the new rockstars And subscribe to new
Rockstar for more analysis of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]